[Music]
hello satan you bossed it
the famous mrs sweeney
captaining campbell i know who you are i
was fully empowered i said there's a
girl i'm gonna marry who did you say
that to my wife i rather think that's
why she divorced me
captain ian campbell has been announced
as the 11th duke of argyll be my duchess
we have to promise that we will never
bore one another
drunk last night you're drunk now stops
me from shooting myself in my face
cause i could just shoot you in the face
when the money runs out because it will
the campaign to remove you will begin
and if you're not very careful you too
will be left with nothing
you were never faithful to me and let's
not pretend that's who we are can you
prove it
do you have a photograph
love letters diaries
because i do
there are reporters outside the house
questions about you and men
[Applause]
you are going to give ian some
achievements don't tell me what to do
because i won't be told
by you orion
or anyone
[Music]
[Music]
you